[Music]
the saddest thing in life is wasted
talent a Broxton I don't know I'm not
sure that I agree that that's the
saddest thing in life is wasted talent
sometimes you can merely tell them to
not actually want to pursue that talent
so I think the saddest thing would be
wishing you had a talent and not having
it to understand just one life you have
to swallow the world is for Salman
Rushdie I mean my children life has a
meaning because it ed the Heroes of
Olympus everyone tries to figure out
what the meaning of life is and I guess
[Music]
this kind of gives you like
like a
like an hourglass of like if time is
running out so you have to do something
before it end nothing ever goes away
until it has taught us what we need to
know but I think about it
is a you pretty much think about that
thing until you learn something from it
yes live your life to its 100% potential
I think that's a good idea
be kind it's the most important thing be
came for a reason be like Jesus follow
Jesus he is the way the truth the life I
would also like to see a different style
of Jesus being followed one that smiles
a smile that is so radiant that it
covers and encompasses everything that
he is about which is forgiveness and
love and like self-respect it's just a
beautiful thing but unfortunately all of
the publication's kind of have them in a
tough spot which personally is not very
inviting and not nice when that's not
what he taught
persecution point but he did so much he
embodied so much one guy changed the
world she was supposed to look at him
like that every day
so I appreciate the person who gave this
to me I am following Jesus I hope
everybody reads and understands the true
way the forgiveness the niceness no
world wars I don't know where he said
let's kick each other's ass over land
but we do that every day doesn't seem
like the way that the Jay wants us to
play I mean come on let's be gay like
happy thank you if you suddenly realized
that you were
amazing I'm a miracle and that nothing
could stop you from enacting good
what would you first act of goodness be
will you do this you're gonna answer it
you speak with somebody that needed it
I'm having the best time of my life if
you want to do anything just go for it
and explore the world just be happy I
mean that that says it all doesn't it
really that's what I'm doing here in
California just kind of having fun and
enjoying life
[Music]
what's up guys my name is Raya and I'm
the owner of this channel I'm also the
person behind the camera I take a minute
to thank all the subscribers I gained so
far and maybe ask the new viewers to the
subscribe button if you liked this
episode or if you're a fan of my channel
in general and yeah into the subscribers
that I have already if you want to help
grow my channel it would mean a lot if
you share in your favorite episode
friend or two or three or four buddies
you want and help me get more
subscribers thank you
[Music]
[Music]